while tensions remain very high between
Harry Megan and her in-laws they are
destroying us a spokesperson for the
South success tells ET they have
received an email invitation to the
king's coronation on May 6 but quote an
immediate decision on whether the Duke
and Duchess will attend will not be
disclosed at this time over the weekend
Harry sat down with trauma expert Dr
Gabor mate inside its Montecito estate
during the live stream which cost nearly
forty dollars to watch Harry joked
thanks for the free session and was
given a live diagnosis of ADD he also
shared my wife saved me adding this clap
back to haters quote I certainly don't
see myself as a victim I do not and have
never looked for sympathy in this the
conversation comes just days after the
king said the sussexes a notice of
eviction from their UK residence
Frogmore Cottage Charles has since
offered the home to his disgraced
brother prince Andrew today I sat down
with his former wife The Duchess of York
Sarah Ferguson in side Manhattans
Alice's Tikka with the Queen's passing
comes the coronation of a new king will
you be attending the coronation well I
don't know yet the corgis won't be there
though oh the corgis won't
you are now the the the keeper of her
cherished corgis yes yes how did you all
make that arrangement I I dog walked
with her a lot it has been a difficult
few months for The Duchess who is still
mourning the loss of her close friend
Lisa Marie Presley I did not realize the
Friendship the two of you had until you
were at her memorial service she
genuinely was one of the kindest people
I've known which reminds me very much of
Diana Sarah is for now focusing on the
positive including being a published
author of more than 50 books her latest
novel a most intriguing lady is out
tomorrow you provided us with a
wonderful heroine in your book Lady Mary
she's trying to find her own way many
similarities that I feel like we see in
you but where did you find the strength
to pave your own path I never give up I
I just am that person I have great faith
Rachel that today is another day and we
can seize it
[Music]